it looks so mundane and yet it is so
important this is the nordstream
pipeline which has long brought gas from
russia to europe it's a mainstay for
untold millions of people
and now it sits
idle switched off by its operator
gazprom russia's biggest company
controlled by the kremlin
it's an act of economic aggression that
could be as consequential as it was
inevitable
putin will make a further step in
cutting supplies it would actually be a
breach of contract so we all hope that
doesn't happen it's clear that if it
does happen there will be consequences
but it's also clear that we have been
getting ready for this risk for months
therefore we shouldn't let it threaten
us
there are five main gas supply routes
between russia and europe
nordstrom one is the biggest pipeline
running from russia to germany
before the war it was delivering more
than 150 million cubic meters of gas per
day
in june gazprom cut that flow to around
60 million because it said of annual
maintenance
but in august the flow dropped again now
down to about 20 percent of capacity and
european gas prices doubled as a result
then on wednesday gazprom halted the
flow of gas completely citing a leak in
the main gas turbine and now the company
says nordstream will remain closed
indefinitely
this is the oil leak gas problem claims
to have hobbled the pipeline few think
it's a plausible excuse russia is using
gas supply as an economic weapon
for decades russia had been a reliable
supplier of energy to europe uh
particularly the cold war they were
consistent supplier of gas to germany
but what we've seen since the invasion
of ukraine and even before that
russia had been limiting gas supplies
into europe to push up prices and put
severe economic pressure on the
continent
it's a view echoed by europe's leaders
charles michelle president of the
european council says russia is now
using gas as a weapon and that energy
independence is a priority
and there is a risk here for vladimir
putin stopping the sale of gas will cost
him billions at a time when he's
fighting an expensive protracted war
and europe's money may not return
so this is all about uncertainty demand
for energy outstripping supply and
spiraling prices the ripples of war
always spread far
adam parsons sky news